there's so many abortion restrictions  being enacted across the country should  American women be concerned that this  Court is going to let their fundamental  right to have access to abortion  services be taken away women should be  concerned because abortion restrictions  impractical affect target poor women and  poor women only many states will never  go back to old ways and what that means  is no matter how respective a particular  state law is if the woman has the means  to go to a neighboring state if she can  buy a plane ticket or a bus ticket and  afford the cost of the procedure she's  safe and she and her daughter's will  always have the choice the people who  don't have the choice about for women  and that frankly doesn't make any sense  as national policy now that it's safer  for women of means we don't see I think  and the same effort put forth to protect  all women to protect women who can't  afford the procedure on their own